les 17 minutes sont des épisodes
spéciaux réservés aux membres de ma page
patronne sur ma page patronne vous
trouverez plus d'une centaine de
publications inédites les épisodes
retour les capsules concept les cours en
visio sans parler de mes articles et des
apéro philo rejoignez-moi sur patronne
pour y accéder le lien est dans la
description
le temps est-il une illusion
dans la longue liste des propriétés que
l'on prête à l'homme il y a la
conscience du temps
l'être humain est un animal qui a
conscience du temps qui passe
que le passé fut que le présent et
que le futur sera
mais le temps est il une réalité
objective
ou bien se pourrait-il qu'il soit une
pure invention de notre esprit
si on prend les choses telles qu'elles
se présentent à nous le temps est une
réalité
à coire connaissons-nous l'existence du
temps
nous la reconnaissons à ses effets
c'est par ses effets que le temps se
manifeste
le vieillissement l'usure la mort
si nous n'étions pas mortelle si nous ne
connaissions pas de fin sans doute ne
serions nous pas affectés par le temps
nous vivrions dans ce qu'il convient
d'appeler un éternel présent
or s'il n'y a que du présent
il n'y a pas de temps
saint-aubin c'est à propos du temps
rien ne passait il n'y aurait point de
temps passé
si rien advenait il n'y aurait point de
temps à venir
et si rien n'était il n'y aurait point
de temps présent
comprenons pas là que la division du
temps en trois dimensions passé présent
et futur
est fondée sur la simple observation des
choses
certaines choses ont été
ménagés sont plus
son passé
vient de se passer
on veut dire que quelque chose vient de
rejoindre le passé
le passé qui subsiste en ou sous la
forme du souvenir
par l'intermédiaire de cette faculté que
la mémoire
mais qui à proprement parler n'existe
plus
repenser au passé c'est repenser à
quelque chose qui n'a plus de réalité
effective
de même pour le futur
nous imaginons le futur
nous anticipons le futur
cette anticipation se fait toujours au
présent
nous projetons notre présent sur le
futur
raison pour laquelle nous prévoyons
souvent très mal le futur qui nous
attend
parce que nous le concevons uniquement
comme un prolongement du présent
cette petite analyse
on a par s
premièrement
tallieu au présent
bien que du présent
car le passé n'existe plus
dur n'existe pas encore
seule forme sous laquelle le passé le
futur existe c'est la forme de la
représentation
de la représentation par l'esprit
deuxièmement qu alors même qu'il n'y a
que du présent il semble qu'ironiquement
le présent soit la seule dimension du
temps qui nous soit inaccessible
car sitôt qu'un événement se présente
c'est à dire se rendent présent il est
aussitôt renvoyé dans le passé
et merci
tu remercies fait déjà partie du passé
le temps donc un paradoxe
alors fois réalité incontournable
inéluctable
rien ni personne n'a le pouvoir de
s'extraire du temps
et allah un pure création de l'esprit
car dès lors que vous cessez de vous
représenter mentalement le passé et le
futur
ce qui reste n'est que pure présent
mais envisage
différents
bergson disait qu'il fallait
différencier deux types de temps
le temps objectif et le temps subjectif
le temps objectif c'est le temps des
horloges
c'est le temps physique
c'est le temps qui vous permet
d'organiser votre emploi du temps
de donner rendez-vous à telle heure
et sur lequel tout le monde peut se
synchroniser
ce temps physique des horloges n'est pas
qu'une simple convention
il est calqué sur un phénomène
astronomique
la rotation de la terre
un jour c'est le temps que met la terre
à faire une rotation sur elle-même
or la rotation de la terre ce n'est pas
une invention
c'est une réalité concrète
réalité d'un cycle
de même que la révolution de la terre
autour du soleil est une réalité
concrète qui définit nos années
dans certaines cultures on parle de mois
lunaire
la durée que mais la lune a effectué son
cycle
tel que nous l'employons c'est le temps
issus des cycles naturels
et si la subdivision de ces cycles en
saison en semaine et en heure relève
bien d'un choix humain
ces cycles n'en sont pas moins une
réalité matérielle
1 c'était pour le temps objectif
mais qu'en est il du temps subjectif
objectif c'est le temps tel que vous le
vivez
tel que vous le vivait intérieurement
prenons un exemple
si vous regardez un film et que vous
vous ennuyez le temps va vous paraître
long
va vous paraître sous-entendu c'est une
impression
une impression subjective
al'inverse
vous vous amusez
vous passer du bon temps c'est le cas de
le dire
passé très vite
il n'exercera pas sur vous de pression
donc subjectivité du temps dans la
mesure où il y a perception du temps
le temps a beau être une réalité
objective il n'existe qu'à travers
l'expérience que vous en faites
du point de vue de la perception une
heure ça ne veut rien dire
tout va dépendre de la manière dont
cette heure va être rempli
bergson distingue ainsi le temps de la
durée
la durée c'est le sentiment du temps
c'est le temps sicaud logique le temps
vécu
et ce temps vécu est bel et bien la
seule voie d'accès autant que nous ayons
voilà pourquoi on peut dire que le temps
est d'abord ce que nous en faisons
nous faisions remarquer tout à l'heure
que le présent n'existait pas
un événement se produit
il appartient déjà au passé
ça c'est un raisonnement logique
or notre rapport au temps n'est pas
nécessairement un rapport logique
vu notre expérience il les possibles de
s'extraire du temps
au sens où il est possible de cesser de
se représenter le temps sous une forme
divisée
il est possible de cesser de penser au
passé de cesser de penser au futur
fusionner avec le présent
fusionner avec le présent c'est se
rendre intégralement disponible par nos
sens et par notre attention
ce qui est actuellement
c'est couper le robinet du mental qui
nous fait constamment sortir du moment
présent
c'est par du moment présent
la présence c'est à dire par la tension
continue aux choses présentes
nous mettrons fin à la division du temps
nous mettons fin
l'illusion du temps
et nous réunissions les trois dimensions
du temps pour ne vivre que dans celle
qui est une réalité pour nous le présent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]